hi everyone I'm a mio Bello I go by
sailor hg on the internet i recently may
have a switch from being a full-time
developer to focusing on computer
science education and i now right Dean's
about how computers work full of
cartoons and drawings and stories I care
a lot thank you I care a lot about tying
computer science to other subjects
especially about the intersection of
technology and art and this intersection
is why today I'm going to talk about the
mathematics of origami particularly I
want to talk about the mathematics
behind one of my favorite origami
theorems and some background here when I
was studying computer science in college
I needed to take a class to fulfill an
advanced algorithms requirement and
instead of taking the class called
advanced algorithms I took the class
called paper folding algorithms which
also counted towards that requirement
when we spent every day talking about
and proving theorems about origami and
this one was one of my favorites so it's
called the fold and cut theorem and it
states that you can generate any
polygamous shape or even multiple shapes
from a piece of paper with just one cut
any polygonal shape just one cut that's
a bold claim but it's been proven by
professor professor Erik Demaine of MIT
who taught the class artist-in-residence
Martin domain of MIT and professor anna
leboeuf of the University of Waterloo
and I'll demonstrate this right now live
with some paper cutting
oh let's see
um
so I'm going to be cutting this
jack-o'-lantern with a single cut if you
fold along all of the lines sorry it's
happened
Oh No
sorry I missed this part
so
so the first time this theorem was ever
referenced was in a Japanese puzzle book
in 1721 and the puzzle book challenged
the reader can you cut out this Chima
which is a lightning shape said to ward
off evil spirits from a piece of paper
with just a single cut and it had a
solution at the back of the book and
just to reiterate this theorem again in
illustration form you can generate any
public inul shape from a piece of paper
with just one cut though you might need
to fold the paper many times before you
can make that cut so now the question
becomes even if we assume that the one
cut theorem is possible how and where do
we fold the paper so that it's in the
right state for the single cut there are
a couple ways of thinking about it
conceptually so let's say that we want
to cut out the shape of a cat with a
single cut we can think of it this way
we want to fold a piece of paper so that
everything that's part of the cat is
above a line and everything that's not
cat is below a line and then we cut at
that line here's another way to think
about it we want to fold a piece of
paper so that the outline of the cat
which is everything that we need to cut
is all aligned on the same line and it
turns out to be this way of thinking
that will help us come up with an
algorithm to find the folds necessary
for the one cut ok so if lining up edges
is important to figuring out an
algorithm for folding before the one cut
let's think of the simplest possible
examples of lining up edges for example
if you wanted to fold the top and the
side of a piece of paper to line up
you'd fold the paper at a 45-degree
angle and this will align the top in the
side and if you have to randomly
oriented lines on a piece of paper and
you wanted to line them up with a fold
you would fold somewhere between the two
lines to assign them to align them but
because somewhere between is too vague
if you extended those lines until they
met somewhere off of the piece of paper
we could see that we're specifically
folding between the two lines at exactly
their angle bisector folding on an angle
bisector is
get lines to line up so how do we
generalize this for getting all of the
edges of the polygon to be collinear for
example what happens when we have a
complicated polygon and a bunch of the
angle bisectors intersect to handle
these kinds of cases we can calculate
something that mathematicians call the
straight skeleton it's called the
straight skeleton because when you
calculate it it ends up looking like it
could be the actual skeletal support
structure for that shape so how do you
calculate it you shrink the original
shape while maintaining constant
perpendicular distance from all from the
original edges and then you trace the
path of the vertices as the shape
shrinks and this is the straight
skeleton and you'll see so far that this
path matches up with the angle bisectors
of the edges and as you're shrinking the
shape you might run into three types of
edge cases as you shrink a shape it
might get so small that it eventually
shrinks to a single point if this
happens you stop our definition of the
straight skeleton is the path of the
vertices as the shape shrinks and if the
shape is a single point it can't shrink
anymore so at this point the simple
skeleton is the path from the original
vertices to that single point as
indicated by the bold lines in this
figure here is another literal edge case
you might run into as you shrink a shape
to edges might merge into a single edge
like the top and bottom of this
rectangle what does this mean for
calculating the straight skeleton just
like in the point case you can't shrink
this edge any further so you include the
merge edge in the straight skeleton
along with a path of the vertices to
this merged edge and the straight
skeleton is shown for this rectangle and
bold finally as you shrink a shape it
might separate into two destroying
shapes and that's also ok just apply the
straight skeleton algorithm to both
shapes recursively
with these rules you can write a program
to calculate the straight skeleton of
polygonal shapes and this screenshot is
from a solver that I wrote and I'll
delude them so you draw your shape and
then you run the algorithm to find
Skelton
so now that we've computed the straight
skeleton of this shape can we fold along
the lines of the skeleton to cut this
gem with a single cut almost so the
straight skeleton is most of but not the
full set of folds that we need to make a
shape with a single cut why do we need
more folds to understand why we'll have
to get into the concept called flat
foldability first so here is a simple
example of why a straight skeleton isn't
fully sufficient for our purposes so
this is a rectangle shown with its
straight skeleton and what would happen
if we try to fold along with skeleton
lines if we try to fold along with
skeleton lines we'd see that it just
doesn't fold into a flat shape and we
need to hold our paper into a flat shape
in order to cut it with one cut and I'll
demonstrate with a piece of paper how
it's impossible to fold this rectangle
with just these fold lines
so this is a rectangle that we saw
earlier and if we fold along these lines
we just can't make it flat
so the problem is that not all sets of
edges fold flat and fold ability is
another area in the field of folding
algorithms formalizing which sets of
edges will fold flat and which cannot
fold flat or even which that to the
edges are impossible to fold and would
result in the paper intersecting with
itself so a set of edges that can be
folded flat is called flat foldable for
this particular shape we would be able
to fold it flat if we added
perpendicular helper fold lines that
extend from the inner skeleton vertices
to the edges of the rectangle and I'll
demonstrate on a piece of paper how just
these two extra folds let you fold this
rectangle flat
so this is a piece of paper with two
extra lines and with those two extra
lines you can fold the slack
so how do we generalize this how can we
add folds to any straight skeleton in
order to make it flat foldable well
first of all we can establish that these
helper folds must meet the shape edges
at 90 degrees because that means that
they're guaranteed not to interfere with
the way that the edges of the shape are
already aligned in a straight line so we
can draw perpendiculars from every
vertex of the straight skeleton to the
edges of the shape that we want to cut
and we might not need all of them but we
do know that none of them will hurt
foldability or a sep one cut ability and
so if we take the shape that we drew
before and it's straight skeleton and
then we add the perpendicular lines from
every straight skeleton vertex to the
edges of the shape this is what we get
and now I'll demonstrate that that was
enough to generate a folding that would
allow you to cut the shape with one cup
so this is the shape that we want to cut
out this is how we folded it along all
the straight skeleton lines and some of
the perpendicular helper lines and now
if we wanted to cut it out we cut it out
with one cut
so I'm excited because there are still
plenty of ways to take this project
further I'd love to add in the
perpendicular lines to the straight to
the app that I made and so that you can
just click a button and I'll draw the
perpendiculars it would also be great to
add in mountain valley fold assignment
and this is yet another exciting part of
foldability theory figuring out which
folds Shuggie Valley folds or mountain
folds and because if you assign them
incorrectly you you won't be able to
fold the shape at all I'd also love to
read some more papers to be able to
implement a program that can handle some
more edge case shapes cuz while I was
implementing with solver I ran into
difficulties handlings extreme concave
shapes and spiral shapes and I look I
read a lot of research papers about this
theorem and it turned out that a robust
implementation of a straight skeleton
solver that can handle any input polygon
is the subject of a few masters and PhD
theses
the things that people documented as
being the most difficult problems we're
similar to the issues i ran into
polygons with extreme concave sections
polygons with a spiral shape and mostly
these problems are because as you shrink
the shape you run into rounding errors
with floating point numbers I'm so one
super interesting paper that I read
instead viewed the polygons as the walls
of a building I am the simple skeleton
as an overhead view of the roof in 3d
space and then trying to solve for the
simple skeleton in 3d prevented a lot of
the floating-point rounding errors so
I'd like to give that implementation a
try thank you so much for listening I
made this into a zine so come find me
later if you would like a copy of the
scene and come find me later if you have
any questions about the talk and I'd
also love to talk to you if you're
interested in computational origami the
intersection of coding an art or in
computer science education and thank you
so much for having
um are there any questions oh yeah so
you know they talk about you can't hold
a piece of paper more than seven times
did that that does not intersect with
this right because it's linh theory or
did that take um so this is just in
theory it it was like another discussion
that we had in class but different from
theory that you can only fold a piece of
paper so many times and a lot of my
friends who do really complicated
origami like start folding with like
onionskin paper that's like super thin
so that you can fold it even more times
yeah um it's I guess the the way that I
ended up doing it like for tests and
stuff was if you make a certain guess
for one being a mountain fold or a
valley fold you keep assigning them
until there's like a contradiction we're
like none of the folds can be assigned
to either of them and then you like you
change your guess and then you keep
doing that in a kind of wrenches out
yeah
um I don't I wanted it to be able to
handle a couple more cases before I put
it up uh yeah um let's see that's
handleable too I guess I didn't have any
examples of it but I I picked the
pumpkin because it was seasonal but if
it's not in September than I usually do
it with a swan and like all the edges
line up so you can still cut it with one
cut even though it's not a symmetrical
because you can still compute the
straight skeleton for non symmetrical
shapes so it doesn't really affect the
computation any other questions yeah
oh right hmm
yeah so that's like the pumpkin was a
bunch of little shapes and you like it I
guess in this case you take this like
the outside as a bounding shape and then
draw like you expand inside yeah
yeah they're always perpendicular and
the reason that they're perpendicular if
it wasn't clear before is if they're
perpendicular than when you fold them it
won't affect the the line that you've
already created so it won't affect the
one cut ability because you're just if
it's if it's making a perpendicular line
with the the edge that you're going to
cut and you fold on that perpendicular
line it's not going to change the shape
of that line yeah
uh-huh I don't know that there are good
idea like there are lots of ways that
you can fold this shape like you could
pick you could pick some some helper
lines and not the others but you might
not use all of them but if you wanted to
you could use all of them but like I
just at the point where it becomes
foldable then you can stop so maybe
maybe there's some interesting theory
around like what are the minimum number
of perpendicular lines but I don't know
anything about that that would be
interesting to research yeah
um I'm not sure I haven't even tried
that I guess I don't know that I've
worked with a language that doesn't have
floating point issues
so so that was like a thing that our
professor covered early on in the class
because I think he was like sensitive to
being asked like what are the practical
uses of this
so one is for packaging so a lot of
folding theory is useful for creating
packaging with like minimal amount of
waste and another one is for like
satellites often have like folding
components that will like fold out like
once a like Regis at like reaches space
so that was another application yeah
um so I I'm not really sure how the
circle would would work with this
because it's not technically a polygon
like the the edges are like infinitely
small
um ok thank you so much